kino europa jetzt für die afg fraktion
der parteichef als nächster redner
dieser aktuellen stunde beantragt von
der linken
herr präsident
liebe gäste auf der besuchertribüne
meine damen und herren liebe landsleute
auch werte vertreter auf der
regierungsbank
es ist gut dass wir hier und heute über
thüringen reden über all das was ich
nach der demokratischen wahl des fdp
kandidaten thomas kemmerich zum
ministerpräsidenten des freistaates
thüringen abgespielt hat also darüber
wie diese demokratische wahl von den
meisten medien und allen parteien mit
ausnahme der afd in den schmutz gezogen
wurde auch von teilen der fdp
ich muss ihnen ehrlich sagen ich hätte
vieles in diesem land für möglich
gehalten spätestens seit unserer
bundeskanzlerin 2015 gegen jedes recht
und gesetz die grenzen öffnete aber das
aber das was nach der rechtmäßigen
demokratischen wahl des fdp kandidaten
thomas kemmerich geschah das hätte ich
mir nun wirklich nicht vorstellen können
und darum sage ich werd die
bundeskanzlerin ihr verhalten und dass
viele ihrer parteifreunde ist zutiefst
beschämend sie haben vor aller welt das
vertrauen in die deutsche demokratie
erschüttert und damit haben sie dem
ansehen deutschlands erheblichen schaden
zugefügt
ja da können sie krakeelen die wahrheit
tut weh denn die wahrheit ist sie und
sie sie haben ihre parteipolitischen
interessen über den parlamentarismus
gestellt ja das muss man sich das muss
man sich einfach mal vergegenwärtigen
der mit einem frisch gewählten fdp
ministerpräsidenten vom fernen südafrika
aus der rücktritt empfohlen
wer während eines staatsbesuchs ordnet
bundeskanzlerin merkel in pretoria an
das muss rückgängig gemacht werden und
das sind zeichen von einer
bananenrepublik muss ihnen sagen und ich
sage es ihnen
wir leben längst in einer republik in
der ein paar rapide an vertrauen und
einfluss verlieren die parteien sich mit
allen mitteln auch mit unlauteren an die
macht klammern
denn was wir in thüringen erlebt haben
war die kriegserklärung des
einparteienstaates an den
parlamentarismus sei
bisher war es ein untrügliches
kennzeichen für diktaturen wenn wahlen
für nichtig erklärt wurden deren ausgang
den herrschenden nicht genehm war seit
dieser woche wissen wir hier wollen
massive kräfte das letztlich nicht mehr
wähler und parlamente entscheiden diese
herrschaften und ihre medialen
steigbügelhalter reden gerne und viel
von demokratie
aber wenn die demokratie zu ergebnissen
führt die nicht in den kram passen dann
pfeifen sie auf den wert der
demokratischen selbstbestimmung dann
treten sie den parlamentarismus mit
füßen
ich habe meine damen und herren ich bin
in der ddr aufgewachsen und war alt
genug zu begreifen wie sich ein system
hinter einer demokratischen fassade
einrichtet angela merkel ist wie ich
selbst ein kind der ddr und dennoch
agiert sie immer stärker im stil einer
staatsratsvorsitzenden als einer
kanzlerin
[Applaus]
nach alter sed und fdj schule annuliert
sie nicht nur einen ministerpräsidenten
wahl nein die stadt stört das fundament
unserer demokratie
die freie meinungsäußerung nur weil ihr
ost beauftragter hirte den
fdp-kandidaten kemmerich zur
unerwünschten wahl gratulierte wurde er
entlassen
und genau so genau so entsteht ein klima
der angst und des hasses angst davor das
falsche zu sagen angst davor die
falschen zu wählen und der hass auf den
vermeintlichen gegner meine damen und
herren mit seiner wahl zum
ministerpräsidenten sind herr kemmerich
und seiner gesamten familie tag und
nacht auf polizeischutz angewiesen
warum wohl gegen ein system dass solche
ängste schürt und instrumentalisiert
sind die ddr bürgern 1989 auf die straße
gegangen aber sie haben sich für die
freiheit nicht erkämpft um die sich nun
wieder zu verlieren weil die altparteien
um ihre existenz fürchten
meine damen und herren
zur demokratie gehört die fähigkeit zum
kompromiss und die bereitschaft und die
kraft niederlagen einstecken und
anerkennen zu können
diese eigenschaften kann ich weder bei
der bundeskanzlerin noch bei weiten
teilen der cdu spd grünen fdp linken und
den medien erkennen
in diesem sinne waren die ereignisse in
thüringen keine schande
wie die bild zeitung urteilte und auch
kein weiterer schritt zur und kultur wie
die zeit schrieb es ist unverantwortlich
den menschen einen solchen unsinn auch
noch einreden zu wollen
thüring war ein fanal die ereignisse
offenbarten den fragilen zustand unserer
demokratie
sie haben uns gezeigt wie leichtfertig
cdu spd grüne fdp linke und teile der
medien unsere freiheit und demokratie
auf spiel setzen
sie werfen uns vor wir seltener maß der
demokratie aber in wirklichkeit tun sie
es selbst
ich plädiere eindringlich dafür dass wir
uns zu einem fairen politischen diskurs
zurückkehren ich danke für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
tino kubala war das für die afd
deren parteivorsitzender oder auch
bundessprecher granit